Hey! Conan here with my good friend, Sona.
Hi.
That was convincing.
I wasn't, I didn't expect you to do that.
We have a very special
announcement for everybody.
That's right, we're teaming
up with Chevrolet. Yes.
And their all electric
EV lineup doing two,
count 'em, two live podcasts
October 20th and October 27th
from the SiriusXM Garage in Los Angeles.
I love doing shows at The Garage.
I do too. It's so much fun.
It's like a nice, intimate show.
Yeah, and it's got kind
of a nightclub feel,
and I like that 'cause I've
never gone to a nightclub.
I always get kicked out.
That's sad. I have.
Yes. They think I'm an underage girl. Yes.
This will be an intimate
recording with only 30
audience members, that's intimate.
Make sure you're following @teamcoco.
Keep listening to the podcast
for a chance to get free tickets, okay?
This live recording will
be sponsored by Chevy
and their line of electric vehicles.
You know what I call electric vehicles?
What?
EVs.
Wow.
Saves time.
That's cool.
That's what I call 'em. EVs.
What do you do with all that extra time?
Well, you know me,
out there working on the abs.
Chevy's taking some of their best known
and most beloved name plates electric.
That's right.
They're designed, built
from the ground up,
taking them into the all-electric future.
That's the future, baby, electric.
It is. Yeah.
It's all about electric.
Chevy is getting out ahead of the curve.
The Chevrolet family of EVs, see that?
I didn't say electric vehicle.
Saved a lot of time.
But then wasted it by explaining.
Yeah. You keep making it worse.
Yeah. Anyway.
Chevrolet's family of EVs
has an impressive range,
awesome technology,
along with the nationwide dealer network
combined with a growing number
of public charging stations
to help you live electric.
That's important.
You need that infrastructure.
Yeah, if you don't have a
place to charge your car,
what are you gonna do?
Yeah. Yeah.
Set up a little solar
panel in the desert? No.
Chevy's got you covered.
They've got you covered.
So to learn more about the
all-electric Chevy EV lineup
head to chevrolet.com/conan
and go to the @teamcoco Instagram page now
to win tickets to the show.
You wanna see these shows.
If you can get there in person,
you get the Conan vibe up close, and Sona.
Yeah.
But I have that
Conan aura
What?
which you can enjoy in public.
Do you?
Yep.
Right there in the Garage.
I'm always near you. I don't feel it.
Is there an odor?
Isn't there like a musky odor?
There's definitely an odor.
Is it pleasant?
I wouldn't say it's pleasant.
Let's cut this off.
Chevy EVs.
Shows. Sirius Garage.
Go to the @teamcoco Instagram page
to win tickets to the show.
I smell nice.